[Music]
Tom Cruise officially sidelined after an
on-set stunt gone wrong so what is the
future of the sixth Mission Impossible
installment now and this as the 55 year
olds injuries may be worse than first
fear a new report says the crews broke
two bones in his ankle after this
frightening stunt mishap the 55 year old
actor was attempting a wire jump between
two buildings Sunday when he smacked
hard into the side of one Cruz and
Mission Impossible producers have yet to
comment on the incident but an ankle
injury is consistent with these images
of Tom immediately after the accident
you can clearly see him limping and
struggling to walk after the impact
crews who's known for doing his own
stunts told us he's recovered from
similar injuries before I mean I've
broken my nose a couple of times I've
done teeth knocked out broken fingers
and my ankle and a bunch of different
things you know but it all comes back
together rather quickly
still the British tabloid the Sun is
reporting the quote Tom did serious
damage and we'll need months to recover
he is the film's biggest star and
everything revolves around him the
newspaper goes on to say that the film's
current release date of July 2018 could
be delayed cruises built the Mission
Impossible franchise with his own
death-defying stunt one
from this famous mountain climbing scene
I think a lot of people are gonna think
most of this stuff is special-effects
but it's not to scaling the world's
tallest building Tom even hung from the
side of an Airbus 400 as it took off if
something went wrong I can't get into
the airplane
are you certifiable doing all these done
I can't help myself I can't let anyone
else have all the fun
now here's the thing tom has another
movie American made coming out on
September 29th his press scheduled for
that would have revolved around the
shooting of Mission Impossible so no
word on how it will be affected
you